it appears a game of who acts first
and right now neither the u.s or iran
are making a move
the u.s has rejected an offer by iran
for it to synchronize a return to the
2015 nuclear deal
with the european union with iran
fulfilling its commitments
that could have allowed both parties to
save face internationally
and at home but the u.s says it's not
ready to rejoin
of course though we are a long way from
that iran has
a distanced itself from compliance on a
number of fronts and there are many
steps in that process i mentioned a
couple of them
uh consulting with our allies consulting
with our partners consulting
uh with uh congress um before we're
reaching the point where we're going to
engage directly with the iranians and
willing to entertain
any sort of proposal the iran deal was
one of the worst and
iran began to reduce its commitments to
the deal after former u.s president
donald trump pulled out and imposed
sanctions on the country
the u.s sees iran's moves as a way of
breaching the deal
known as the joint comprehensive plan of
action a view not shared by iran
president hassan rouhani says his
country is waiting on the u.s
to right the wrongs of the trump era
amri
americans must return to the resolution
to international law and a resolution
that was passed unanimously by the u.n
security council
if we see goodwill gesture we will show
it too if we see action
we'll show it as well if we see
commitment our response will be full
commitment
in recent days iran has increased the
number of advanced centrifuges at its
main nuclear plant
it allows the country to enrich uranium
quicker and to a higher degree
something that concerns western powers
the eu
is stuck in the middle urging both to
talk but with little power to make that
happen
for now nothing has changed president
joe biden's administration has not
lifted sanctions
imposed under trump and there's still
considerable mistrust between the two
countries
assad beg al-jazeera